驚くことに今年ももう終わりですよ2016年もおつかれさまでした
今年から動画を見始めた方も昔から観てくださる方のいつも動画を見てくださり
コメントをしてくださって応援してくださって本当にありがとうございますみなさま
2016年いかがだったでしょうか僕の今年はですねちょっと去年とはだいぶ変わり
まして7まあまあ男優区
が終わったということでカリスマニートではありません youtube にもとこう
使うを入れるとしなって思ってたんですけどもまぁ今年は根三田動画に力を入れるよう
な性質ではなかったですね
うわぁて右手だったわけじゃないですよ部屋抜いてたわけじゃないんですけども
動画っていうよりかイベントとか動画以外のところに結構この力を入れることが多かっ
たです何でなかなか
忙しい年でしたね
何だろうな動画以外でこんなにからいろんなことに挑戦できたとしかなが思いました
っていうフェスとかもあって全国いろんなところもありました豆腐と厳しいとかでも
行ったことなかったんですよ初めて行ったところで
6弾絶対動画作ってるだけじゃ会えないなっていう方と実際に会うことができたりして
とてもいい痛になりましたやっぱり今年の動画全部見返すとねこんなんか
いろいろ多い出しちゃいました今年なかった奴はこんな感じでした
どうぞあーっはっはっは
ああああああ
[音楽]
23実施中50 r
お菓子は食べません
car
さくさくさくトレッカー聞こえる
しっかり幹部のを確かめてから買いましょう
日食べて頑張って
wh
ああああああ
のハードルほんとえええええええ
今あぁ
ano ano ne
dare
ああああああ
あっはぁああああああ
ん
[音楽]
ああああああああ
あったんだあああん
米韓がないんです
うわああああっはぁ
何言おうと気がついたら自分でパパ区
pandan
[音楽]
voodoo
んじゃおねえさん女性 o
ha
アンダーまでございます
voodoo
できました kimi ni あれば
平王
22万うわぁすっ
ええええええ
ano あとはーバッハ
ああああああ
もち5位 the filter
ええええええ
だ言えらあああああああ
思って本当に浮いてるよ
リポいっぱいパワー欠片ってああ
てめっちーこないうんやばいよ1年でこれだけは探索になりました
得だから買った
[音楽]
ああああああ
久保 ana
wh
と言ってこんな考えを話しています振ってるよん
ano
ん
ああああああ
さあ3年か16に行ってきますみさ
re えっ
goo
ああああああ
へいへいああ
car
[音楽]
はぁ
tar
あああああああっうち5割の誰かはずだった
あじゃあ
toranoana
ええええええ
ああああああああ
ben hao
ああああああああああああ
ああああああああ
ああっ
ああああああ
wh
car
坂田の方にがてもあるんですよはぁ
ああああああああああああああああああ
ああああああ
デポの振るう6点でしたあーーん
やっと4分たチュられた形だった
rar
大きくなったらこんなにオペルは彼に言って出したら友達になれない
ねうんごめんね入って行けば2016年の初めそそいかがだったでしょうか
あの正直速悔しいとスでしたどうか外で入れる頑張れ多分ですねちょっとその忙しかっ
たりしてメインチャンネルにこう全力投球みたいな感じにちょっとできなかったので
本当はねもっといろんなことしたらいいでしょいろんな道が作りたかったね
ですけど色々時間とか東京に行くことも多くてあんまりそれができなかったので来年は
来年になったら考えますすぐイベントからいろんなステージに立たせていただいたよ
思ったことは僕は喋るキャラではありません僕されるのあんま好きじゃないっスよさ
れるなわけじゃないんで僕はこうやってる
王子でカメラに向かっておしゃべりしてそれを編集したりしてあれば僕はで動画を作る
人間なのかなっていうことがちょっと思いました2017年はいろんな道が作れたら
いいなとは大ていますまた来 never
始めた超よろしくお願い致します
じゃーん
黒が3強がいいんだよな
me
あっはっ